Hello
everyone,
and welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
Today it is August 9th, 2021,
and we're here in Guest
stream number 8.1
with Mark Miller and guests.
So this is going to be an awesome
presentation followed by a discussion
so if you have any questions
during the presentation,
please put them in the live chat
and we'll make sure to ask the panel
at the end of the presentation.
So thanks again
to all of our great guests for coming on
and please take it away.
Thank you. Excellent.
Thanks for that, Daniel.
OK, I'm just going to share my screen OK?
Can you turn on screen
cheering for me on your side?
It's under the advanced.
So at the bottom
where it says share screen,
there should be a little little arrow
and click that.
There should be an advanced feature
and then should say allow.
Got it. OK. Yeah. That's it, huh?
Great.
How's that?
Can you just see my slide? Looks great.
Excellent.
Great. OK, well, Daniel, thanks.
Thanks so much, man, for the invitation
to come and give the talk.
I mean, we've been trying to get
we've been trying to find an opportunity
to speak together
for a couple of months now.
Well, since I moved to Japan.
So I'm excited to be here,
and I'm excited
to be talking about this topic,
which we're, we're really excited about.
It's a new paper that actually Julian
Kiverstein, who's here right now,
and myself and Eric Wrightfeld
have a preprint out right now
in the paper titled titled On the Predictive
Dynamics of Happiness and Wellbeing.
We're also anticipating that
Ines Hippolito and Lars Sandved-Smith
will be here this evening.
Lars has had a slight emergency
so he's on the road, but we're hoping
he'll be able to call in
because actually the work that we feature
in this paper, it builds on or it's
really closely related with the research
that Ines and Lars are doing.
So the idea was
that we're going to be able to get we're
going to be able to really talk to them
about their individual portions.
So hopefully they're on the stream
by the time we hit that place.
And if it turns out that they're not,
that's OK.
We can just go through
and then we can chat at the end.
If you don't know me,
my name is Mark Miller.
I'm an assistant professor
at the University of Hokkaido
in their Center
for Human Nature, Artificial Intelligence
and Neuroscience
and I am an active inference researcher.
Right. So
let's see
right.
So I guess probably lots of people
who are listening to the stream tonight
and definitely
the guests who are here right now.
Hayden is great. You read it right on.
I know that recently
there's been a huge amount of research
coming out that's linking
using the active inference
framework in order to investigate
all sorts of psycho pathologies,
you know, mostly finding a home
in computational psychiatry circles,
but really where we're seeing active
inference accounts come up,
you know, relating to depression
and addiction and OCD and schizophrenia.
And so there's some sleep disorders
and all sorts.
And well, there is this sort of active
inference boom right now in relationship
to computational psychiatry
and in particular psychopathology.
We're not seeing any
we're really talking about
how we might apply active inference
frameworks to the theoretical
and formal approach
of discussing things like well-being.
So, you know, all those topics
that would naturally fit in
something like a positive psychology
are still primarily being overlooked.
Although, you know,
in all fairness, we are
starting to see it come up at the edges
because we're starting to see people talk
about the benefits of hallucinogens
and also the benefits of meditation.
So that was part of our motivation
in writing this paper, was to see
if there was anything interesting
to say in a positive account yet,
not just the negative account,
but the positive account.
The other reason why we decided to write
this paper was because
actually Julian and Eric
and I have written a series of papers now
on psychopaths allergies, in particular
using the Active Inference Framework.
So we have papers now on depression
and mood disorders and addiction
and depersonalization and OCD,
and we started to see that
there were some shared characteristics
between these various psychopathology is
if you look at them through the sort of
computational lens of active inference
and seeing
those shared characteristics
sort of started providing,
we think, clues about,
you know, what might be going right
when a human is happy, healthy and well.
And that's what our paper is about
and that's what this stream
will be about as well.
Looking a little bit more at what
some of the predictive dynamics might be
that are underlying
subjective
happiness and overall well-being.
And of course, it's a big topic.
So we're not trying to exhaust
you know, we're not trying to exhaust
the whole of what wellbeing would be, but
rather just taking a sort of first step
to see if we can work out some of that,
some of the points
that might be interesting.
So since I have these lovely people here
tonight with me,
I've decided to make my presentation
relatively short I hope it
won't be any more than sort of 30 minutes
all said and done.
I'm going to pitch it
at a relatively high level of abstraction
because I think there's like
a number of nice moves I'd like to give
to the audience here tonight to sort of
provoke research and provoke some ideas.
And if you're interested
more in the nitty gritty
we have the paper out in pre-print,
so you're, you're more than welcome to go
and actually check out the paper.
And, and of course, if any questions come
up, we can talk about that as well.
Great. OK, so
so I think
a sort of natural place
to start thinking about the relationship
between active inference and well-being
is to think about optimality
in cognitive neuroscience and psychology
today, wellbeing is often spoke of
as a form of optimal
psychological functioning.
But what exactly optimal means
is not very well explained usually,
or at least it's underdeveloped.
And of course as a free energy
principle and active inference
framework researcher.
When you look at that, you
the first thing I thought was, well,
there's a natural way to sort of
be thinking about optimal lity
in terms of the active inference
framework for energy minimization
over the long run approximates
optimal vision inference, right?
That is sort of Bayesian inference
is a form of optimal belief updating.
So that fact in some way
already gives us,
you know,
it gives the free energy principle
and the active inference framework,
you might think a sort of normativity
already, you know, predictive systems
tend to create or strive towards
an optimal set between their phenotypic
self-organization
and the sort of statistical regularities
that they encounter
in their environments.
So we think that an important part
of well-being
from this perspective
is going to have something to do
with being a good predictor
of the sort of hidden causes.
So that's both in the environment
and inside the agent
of the sort of sensory states
that we tend to encounter.
And of course, that crucially relies
on our being able to optimally update
our generative model in ways that are
life sustaining and flourishing inducing.
And I don't
think that that's an incredible stretch.
Just as an opening gambit
you know, we know that well-being
is closely related with health in various
various layers of health,
you know, mental health and emotional
health and physical health and on good
predictors, they tend to self-organize
in ways that allow them to maintain hope
homeostasis across various contexts.
And over the long term.
Right.
So, oh,
and you know, and sort of best of all,
if we think along these lines,
which I think
could be fruitful lines to think along
than we have at our disposal,
as lots of the listeners today
already know,
this sort of ever evolving
and ever growing mathematical suite
to help us describe what is a good model,
what's a good model all about.
So that's our starting point.
Our starting point was to think, well,
maybe wellbeing could be discussed
broadly as a kind of optimal updating.
Yeah, and the goodness,
the goodness of the generative model
that the agent uses to form beliefs
and control their actions in life
sustaining ways over the long term.
OK, so that's a good start
and I think it fits very nicely
with what we already know about
lots of psychopathology in particular.
That psychopathology is are characterized
by suboptimal beliefs
and the sorts of behaviors
that come from having suboptimal beliefs.
Depression is a good example.
It's just one out of a hat though,
really.
I think if you look at any
psychopathology, you're going to find
some sort of bad belief is at play.
At some level of the hierarchy.
I think depression is a nice example.
You know, recent accounts of depression
and not just from the active
inference camp are highlighting
the role that rigid beliefs
about one's inability
to manage the complexities of their life,
including especially
the social complexities of their life,
is playing a major role
in depressive symptoms.
And we've written a paper
on this pretty recently,
and in that paper we are using the active
inference framework.
We argued that when an agent is met
with enough persistent volatility,
then they can eventually develop
a high level prior about their own hype.
High level prior belief about their own
inability to manage volatility.
And when you get that high level prior
installed,
something pretty nasty can happen, right?
The system, a predictive system
then starts selectively
sampling the world
to try to confirm that hypothesis.
And in fact that down regulates
any sort of counter-evidence
that goes against that deep prior,
that deep pathological prior.
So so that even when the situation
changes, you know,
if the agent finds themselves
in more positively predictable
situations, they tend to hold on
to that belief in volatility.
And that's really about what we think
is that pathological moment
so another way of saying that
is that an agent,
at least a depressive agent,
has become overly confident
that it is uncertain, it's overly
confident about being uncertain.
Right.
The only people who've said that
Clarkin colleagues
have written a fantastic paper,
definitely check it out
if you don't know it.
And in that they come to the same
conclusions they write in this sense,
we might conjecture that major depression
occurs when the brain is certain
that it will encounter
an uncertain environment.
OK, and
as we all know, you know,
due to the central role that prediction
plays in sculpting our experience
and directing our behaviors, of course,
as soon as we have a high level bias
like this installed,
then it has tremendous power to produce
exactly the outcomes
that would
that would confirm those biases.
It's one of the problems
of being a predictive agent.
You know, the predictive system
is really good for lots of things.
But one of the problems is there's this
sort of deep self-fulfilling prophecy
that can occur OK?
The rigidity of these bad beliefs
is especially important here.
And it comes up again when we start
thinking about what well-being might be.
You know, there's mounting evidence
that cognitive rigidity,
you know, the sort of stickiness
of bad beliefs
that there are basic feature of
psychopathology is and in fact, you know,
some people are even saying
that it might be the root cause
of all psychopathology.
And I don't think we disagree.
There's a nice essay on article
about this if you
if you're interested in that point.
And I think I might just take a
take a little break there
and hand it over to a nurse and nurse,
have Alito has a really just a fantastic
forthcoming paper coming out that
everyone should be excited to be reading,
which offers a really beautiful
computationally rich account
of how insulated internal states.
Yeah.
When these bad beliefs sort of get stuck
and then they resist updating
how that creates
the sorts of pathological belief
systems, the pathological behaviors
that we see in psychopathology.
So if it's OK
and I'm just going to stop share
and let you maybe talk a little bit
about insulated bad beliefs
and then I'll pick it up from here
and keep going on to wellbeing.
Is that OK?
Yes, sure.
Hi, everyone.
Can you hear me and Siri?
Yeah, OK, great.
So first of all, thanks so much
for a lark for inviting me to be here.
And it's always such a pleasure
to be here with Daniel
for this wonderful session.
And hi Julian,
very nice to see you as well.
So I'll just now share my screen
if I think that's possible.
Yeah,
and I see.
That.
OK, so for some reason
I'm not able to share my screen.
I think it should
maybe try again.
To. No,
it doesn't go through for some reason.
Strange.
It works for me.
Fine.
Yeah.
I mean,
I have no idea.
We could go for a
an audio thought
or you can try to share it.
Later.
Let me just leave and come back
if that's OK.
Maybe that's good. You know, the trick.
Is this is this
is the new world of technology, isn't it?
You have to do everything on the fly.
You have to do everything on the fly
and be willing to adapt.
I have one interim question.
Yeah, please. Yeah, I hit it.
Were you working on active inference
or interested in those approaches?
It then came to be studying
psycho pathology
or just wellbeing more broadly,
or was it the other direction?
Like which way did you go
this intersection from?
Yeah, you're right.
And it started the other way around.
So in my master's
in which Julian was my advisor
at the University of Edinburgh in 2010,
the last chapter of my senior
thesis was a proposal.
So I was working on empathy, looking at,
you know,
philosophy and cognitive science
of empathy, looking at dynamics systems,
theories of emotion.
The last chapter was on predictive
processing and active inference.
And then I got to do my PhD with Andy
Clarke, specifically on active inference,
and then it grew out of doing that
into psychopathology.
Yeah, we got it very good.
Because we got some technical
difficulties, but we are now good.
OK, all right.
You can see it fine. Yep.
Yep. Nice work.
Thanks. In this continue.
Effect. OK, so all right.
So yeah, so this work is on the
what we call psychotic blankets.
And this is something that I've been
working on for the last few months
with two different groups
applying this to different
two different things.
So one specifically schizophrenia
specifically, and the other one is
this embodiment
so what I thought I would do here today
be to do sort of like a combination
between the two
so that to get a bigger picture
of what we have in mind
with, with,
with applying this particular framework.
So yeah. So
let me just give some like framing
about where this comes from
and why I'm motivated to a little bit.
So we always depart from this concept
that Mark also just mentioned
and self-organization,
which is super relevant to these things
that we are talking about
when we refer to wellbeing
and mental health and all of that.
And as a few words about that
and emergence of order from disorder
and specifically without any intervention
from the external intervention
that is external to the system.
And then
what is important for us
is to think of self-organization
as a pattern or an arrangement
that gives rise to a specific way
in which the system is self producing
and self distinguishing.
And here
and not to the in activist literature
so but the idea here
that the fundamental concept
is in self-organizing part
and that comes up
this is why,
why are we talking about that?
Because we want to look at how
the systems or the organisms as a whole
are interacting with environment
in a way that has been called
in embodied literature
as attunement with the environment.
Right?
So the idea there is that
these organisms are
that systems are attuned with environment
and in a way that they will show
a certain specific part
and part of the arrangement
that will be distinct
from, for example, systems
that are not attuned to the environment.
And this is very well known in the whole
bulk of literature,
this embodiment and phenomenology.
So the idea that we want to pursue
here is actually relating to a little bit
to complex systems theory
in which we want to say that
this differentiation between embodiment
in this environment or different patterns
it doesn't mean that the system
that's a system
that is not adjusted to the environment
should be considered disordered,
but instead that it has a different
kind of order. Right.
So here would be sort of
like rejecting a little bit
the competition
with the pounds of psychopathology
as simply a disorder or a disorder or
an illness and opening up a little bit of
not more like broad scope or a spectrum
of to talk about mental health.
So then if we set up things like that,
then what needs to be explained
is how these sulfonamides
behavior of situated organisms
come to be altered in a certain way
rather than another.
And then it will be now
talking about mental health.
So then we think that
active inference is a very interesting
and useful tool precisely to think
about these self-organization,
the patterns that come from self
optimization.
We think about active inference
as a model of how
living things adjust to the environment
and we all know what active inference is.
So just to highlight what is relevant
here for us in terms of pattern dynamics
we think that it is a nice model
that when associated with tools
such as linkage or normalization group,
it can be applied to many different
scales of self-organizing activity.
And that's where we find
all of these patterns of our interest,
of our scientific interest.
So it is useful to explain these gradient
spectrums of kinds of bottoms of order
in self-organizing systems.
Let's just let you decide, you
say we take it as a model in this case.
So it means that we have not committing
to the to the realist view of the facts.
Let's say that the phenomenon studied
conducting ontological process
or leverages the conceptual tool,
but that the tool is really important
and useful for us to understand
such an phenomenon in this case
particular what you want to understand
is this embodiment,
right?
So we all know active inference.
But again, let me just highlight
just some important points
to understand
benzos, psychotic blankets later on.
So here are the ideas
that self-organizing
self producing, self distinguishing
system correspond to the internal states
which affect and which affect and affect
and are affected by the environment.
And external state
via a set of other states such
as the active and the sensory states.
Active and sensory states
are then constructed as influencing one
another, giving rise to a certain part,
and of self-organization.
And this is what's going to be relevant
for later on.
So in a way, what we want to say
is that, well, not just a system
that self-organize is a system
that minimizes the free energy,
which we all know can also be
in this uncertainty or entropy and so on.
Right.
But in a justice system
would be something like that, a system
that is just well adjusted
to its environment and for technicalities
obviously there are references
on the bottom.
Now, moving on to this embodiment
and then later on applying
want to apply these active inference
strategy
to further highlight or understand
what is going on with this embodiment.
Just a
few words about this embodiment
literature.
So the idea is
that comes from phenomenology
and the little bit from existentialist
philosophy and the idea is that
the primary experience of the body
is the body experience as such.
And this is really crucial
The thing is that this experience of
the body of subject can be lost,
and in which case
the body is inspected as an object
more like outside of scientific interest.
And here is what the literature says,
and that's
when this embodiment comes up
is on the body all the sudden ceases
to be experienced as a subject
and is now inspected as an object.
So what happens is in exploring and
interacting with the local environment,
we usually typically with an
not tend to our body.
We just take it for granted
that our body allows us
access, move around, interact,
explore the world.
So what we and it is
not until we cannot do these things or
something is wrong, that we will direct
our awareness towards the body
and then the body becomes salient
as an object of inquiry.
And it's right here at this point
where we find these embodiment.
It's when we cannot explore or interact
to the world as one would like.
So in a way, we can
distinguish embodiment in this embodiment
by saying, for example,
or just highlighting features.
Of course,
the literature is vast,
but I think that these are the ones
that work for us here.
Embodiment is an attunement
with the environment that is allowed
or enabled by having an experience of
the body is a subject
and that gets us attuned
to the environment
through a bodily self awareness
or something that is embodied
self awareness that is that is felt,
and there's embodiment on the other
hand is a visit to the environment
because it is a loss of the body.
As a subject body becomes an object,
there's a disappointment
and a diminished body awareness.
So this comes from the literature
and it is interesting for us here. Why?
Because then there's been
this links that have been made
between psychopathology and psychedelics
and this embodiment
as in this embodiment being something
that is reported in different
psychopathology such as vignette
personalization, even major depression
or other psychopathology
that involved rumination.
And another very important thing
is that this embodiment also cures
and these disorders reported in the in
psychedelics intake
and this has been even more relevant
to studying these embodiments
precisely in the psychedelic renaissance
that we are witnessing today.
And also another point that I want
to make just here, so in brackets
is just that this embodiment does not
necessarily need to be a bad thing
we usually put things in good or bad,
right or wrong, but it doesn't need
to be a bad thing because if we do get
some sort of physical effects
positive effects from psychedelics,
this precisely by having these
these embodied experience.
So it's just a different way
of interacting with the world.
And that's why we want to pursue
less of a disorder way.
And much more often
there's a spectrum of different path
turns off interaction with the world.
Right. OK, so just that not
then I want to look at this embodiment
and how we can use active inference
to understand
this embodiment in two ways.
One is the cycle,
the psychology of this embodiment.
So how that's the one that is felt
psychologically
and the other one
is the neurobiology of this embodiment.
So as we have said, this embodiment
is the loss of the body as a subject
which is replaced by
some formal intellectual effort.
So imagine that you now don't
have these broadly access to the world.
That is not possible
because that's exactly what is lost
by psychopathology or psychedelics intake
and many other things.
Right so then
try to cope and compensate
by literally engaging
in making inferences
about the state of affairs.
So here we could use a little bit
of literature and sophisticated
affective inference,
which is conscious reasoning and planning
and policy selection that you engage
now with having loss these access
to the world through the body.
Now our
hypothesis is that the issue
is that in this disembodied
because we all engage in
sophisticated activity, that's all fine.
The difficulty is that in the case
of this embodiment
experience, these inference is insulated,
is isolated,
because what has been lost
is the access to the world
so then what happens is
so we will have something
that looks like this.
So we all know this is skin here, right?
And what we want to say
is that what is lost
now is the influences
between sensory and active states
and let me guide you through it.
So let's just
focus on the figure for now.
So we have internal states
as being disembodied reasoning.
So as subject that has lost this axis
of bodily access to the world
because it is not health as a subject.
So we've got this disembodied
reasoning as internal states.
Then we have external states
as the environment with that
that the subject
wants to explore and interact with.
And then we have a sensory state
the environmental constraints,
so these aspects
that should influence the subject.
And then as active states,
we have the effectivity
and the ways
in which the subject can affect
and benefit
and be affected by the environment.
But what has been lost here is
that there is
an imbalance between sensory
and active state.
So for one active states
are not sensitive
to sensory state, right?
So it is these effectivity
of this possibility
of being affected by the environment
that is not possible. Why?
Because the access to the body
as a subject
has been lost in this psychopathology
or psychedelics
as that label,
as this embodiment experience.
So as a coping mechanism,
what is going to happen
is there will be an increase of activity
of the activity of active states
by increasing the issuing of inferences
about the world.
So I do not understand
what is going on,
but I'm going to continue
to think about it and make
and develop theories
about what is going on.
The problem is that we can't
we all engage in these
developing theories and inferences
about what we think is the likelihood
of the state of affairs.
The situation here in this embodiment
just that
these inferences are disembodied,
so they tend to be false beliefs,
and that's because of the insulation
of eternal state.
What does this mean?
This means that that is not so.
The access that we have to
the world through our lives will be
is what is lost.
So then subject in a situation
where your only hope
is to increase in increased active state,
to make more inferences
about the world, to cope with death loss,
and then tendency is to have false
beliefs.
That's when we start entering the realm
of psychopathology and psychosis
so in these
disembodied cases,
this is actually a very important point
because one could say, OK,
so then the problem is the reason.
The level of reason
is on the level of, for example, state
terminal states, as we have set up here.
Now, the problem is not on the level
of internal states.
Reasoning is fine.
The inference mechanisms are working
perfect they find the subject can engage
in reason.
It can make you princess.
The problem is inside the blanket
the problem is in the unbalance
that there is between
active and sensory states
because those are the ones
that are supposed to directly influence
one another.
Such that indirectly there's a connection
between internal and external state.
But it is these direct influence
between sensory and active states
that is problematic.
They are not communicating well.
They're not influencing themselves
or each other in a balanced way.
In a sense,
and balancing the sense
that active states become super active
and sensory states cannot influence
active state
so then what we get,
we get to this idea of a psychotic
Markov linkage, which is if
we have this sort of arrangement
where there's a problem between
the balance of the strength of influences
between sensory and active state,
then we have a problem of the generation
of false beliefs.
The problem
being that these beliefs that are issued
by active states,
they cannot be updated by the world
because it is precisely this access
to the world that has been lost,
lost by virtue of having lost
the body as a subject
so then
because of these these attunement
that we can actually explain
as what is occurring inside the blanket
the reasoning subject makes inference
about entrances about world.
But these reasoning, of course, from
within the lack of experience of the body
as a subject
so it occurs in a selective manner.
And this is consistent actually
with a longstanding
literature and criminology of psychosis
where the subject and a
bunch of literature on psychosis
linked to solipsistic behavior
like shifting drawing and painting
and also the philosophical idea,
which is the philosophical idea
that only one's mind is short to exist.
And then some, some reports
I find quite interesting.
So some patients will report
I was no longer
sure that I was still the same person.
I became one with other creatures
or objects.
I lost the sense of my own boundaries.
When I have an experience
I often did not know which was mine.
Or the experience of someone else.
So it is quite interesting
what can be lost
when we lose these body as a subject
as it is developed in phenomenology.
This also happens a little bit
in the personalization disorder,
for example, showing this is important,
which is to invent when making people
feel estranged and detached
from their self, body and the world
OK, so this is all I have on
this and on the psychology
of this embodiment, and I would like
to turn to the neurobiology
and also in dance, apply
the same framework
now to the neurobiology of of
line neurobiologists.
So we think that applying
the same reasoning is consistent.
So this attunement that you were talking
about felt at agent level
should also be expected
that the neural neurological states.
So that's our hypothesis.
So I think that's what our two places are
two good candidates
for perception
and interception will be good candidates
so proprioception as a system underlying
movement and location of the body of
the environment as well as interception
as the system responsible
for homeostasis.
These are good candidates
we think for the neurobiology biology
of this general is a treatment
that is felt in this embodiment
so focus
active and interest, active systems
just like any situated organism can be
conceived this self-organizing system.
So we apply exactly the same principle
as we would apply to
the agent as a self-organizing system.
So the question then that we have is
what is the factor
that is at the basis of this
of a neuro biological pattern
underlying proprioception
and interception that will show
these maladjustment to the environment
so if we expect
the same sort of mechanism
or organization
or dynamics as to the heel of agent
and that we were just talking about, then
how are we going to find this out as well
in the neurobiology?
So we think that just like
in psychological experience, of this
embodiment where the agent becomes
insolated from the world,
and in this case we say
by virtue of losing the body is subject,
the answer will reside
in biological isolation
now I'm going to focus now on
interception because I don't have time
to also cover proprioception.
And I think that this does give us here
some very, very cool insights so
I'm going to focus now on the work
brought by Barrett and Siemens on these
receptive connections in the brain.
And they have a very cold model
which they call embodied
predictive interception coding model.
And the goal
there is to integrate an anatomical model
of course, cortical connections
with active inference principles,
and they propose a very cool thing,
which is that to a granular, visceral
motor cortices contribute to interception
by issuing interception predictions.
So more specifically,
what they want to say is that
the granular limbic regions that regulate
visceral motor of the body's
internal milieu, that is the visceral
motor cortex is less.
So this is their focus
and where they think they will find
the intercept system
and where they apply the model.
Now, so you can see the a
granular cortex here on the left.
And one very interesting thing
that I'm just going
to draw your attention to
and then if you feel
that you'd like to really super
interesting paper, then please go for it.
But I just want to draw your attention
to the fact that on the left side
you have the cortex.
And there's one thing that is missing
from the granular cortex as opposed
to the these granular and the granular
of course is says.
So what is missing is the layer four.
And what happens with that
is that there won't be
you cannot see there
any connection neurons.
So that's pretty cool
because that will give us an idea
that there is no connection
or neurons in the eight granular cortex.
So just
I'm just going to leave that out there
and just moving forward
to just like understanding
the third piece
of the predictive intercept
model,
they claim
that there is an intercept of the brain
in which a granular core
to send visceral motor
predictions to the body
and transmit intercept to predictions
about the visceral sensory
consequences of those predictions.
So they'll tell us that
the granular, visceral motor cortex
is estimate the balance
between the autonomic,
metabolic and immunological resources
that are available to the body
and the predictive requirements
of the body based on past experience.
Right.
So this is going to be very important
for us
because a chronic imbalance
on those things that I was just
mentioning can be
which can be caused by constantly
predicting the need
for more metabolic energy
to meet the demands or stressors,
can produce the well known depression
related disruption.
And it can also eventually down regulate
down regulation of hypothalamus or
oxygen's negative feedback loops
resulting in chronic hyper cortisol
and in turn can also promote
pro-inflammatory state.
So this is like some of the problems
of having
an imbalance
on the level of the autonomic metabolic
and logical resources,
which is what's the intercept of system
should be able to do is to keep
those steps nice balance, right?
So then applying exactly the same,
the same framework, the same model
that we apply to the whole body,
this embodiment of the generalized
female, this embodiment
that is vastly described
in the phenomenology literature
applying system to neurobiology
of central receptive system,
then what we get is something that can be
seemed as like quite similar
an imbalance
between sensory and active state.
So let me just go through the figures.
So here in this
figure, internal states are
or are
correspond to the receptive system
and the external environment,
whichever the multi scale systems,
the receptive system is part of.
And then we have active states
is that a granular Portis Scorsese's
that send visceral motor predictions
and then we have center stage status,
the requirements of the body
given the history that the body knows
to be required for homeostasis.
So then in this sense
Hollywood half is that active
states
are not sensitive to sensory state.
So even though active states can become
as a coping mechanism much more active
and send much more predictions
about what is going on,
what's the state of affairs
because I'm not receiving any information
from the requirements of the body.
So the sensory states.
So what will happen
then because of this installation
is that a false
belief is going to be generated
so this will correspond
to constantly prediction
of the needs for more metabolic energy
to meet the demands of the stresses.
So in the sense we have here another case
of what we call a psychotic Markov
Blanca twice it's psychotic
because it delivers.
If there is this lack or because
imbalance between sensory states
are the thing, for instance,
between sensory states and active states,
then what we should
expect is a generation of a false belief.
And they can also expect
that at a nearby logical level,
which is also supported
by empirical evidence.
So this is what I want to say,
just thinking
I'm thinking of these collaborators here
that I've been thinking about
and guiding me
through as well. These ideas
thank
you for this really interesting stuff.
So I guess we'll return to Mark
and then anybody.
Yep. Anyone's free to ask a question
in live chat and I'm writing things down
and then after this second piece of
the presentation will have a discussion.
So thanks again. Go for it, Mark.
Yeah, that was great.
Thank you so much. Wow,
it's so interesting.
And I haven't heard some of your stuff
about this embodiment yet.
And you know, also this is a research
program that I'm extremely interested in.
So I'll be picking your brain
at the end of the Q&A.
And also after after this event,
what might what wasn't made obvious in
and as this talk, but I think is implied,
is that the stickiness,
the stickiness of these belief systems
and what's helping them
become insulated is a story
about how precision is being estimated
and how precision is being deployed.
That's surely one of the mechanisms
that is creating an imbalance
between active and sensory states.
So, you know, how precision is estimated
is really
the agent's ability to assess
the uncertainty of its own priors.
And when that's working right then
those estimation should results
inappropriate model updating.
You know, you shouldn't get stuck in an
insulated in an insulated situation,
but rather you should know, well,
that's not working out the right way.
And so appropriate updating should occur.
And we know that like maladaptive
precision estimation is disastrous.
Right.
And we're seeing it everywhere
in the psychopathology literature today.
You know, schizophrenic delusion is being
characterized
as too little precision on sensory data.
Which is putting this heavy emphasis on
just top down predictions.
And that's why you're seeing the world
in a way that isn't being anchored
by what's really happening.
And of course, NASD is a little bit
the flip, right?
Too much precision on prediction errors
creates a lot of a lot of volatility
and a lot of difficulty
establishing good high level predictions
and as a quick
side note, you know that
the kind of insulated,
insulated outcomes
that create these maladaptive
self-organizing styles,
they can occur in lots of ways.
Right? So for instance.
Oh, yeah.
So addictive substances is one good way,
right?
Addictive substances impact directly
precision estimation machinery, right.
In the way that the addictive substance
engages the dopamine system.
So addictive substances
are setting precision outright in a way.
So no wonder they can create
these sort of suboptimal styles.
But societal expectations
do the same sort of thing,
you know, sub optimally
pinning precision on
expectations about success, for example,
you know,
so you can have cultural
pinning of precision
that you should achieve
a certain level of success in your life.
And, you know,
we have deep running relationships
between perfectionism and depression,
for example, and again,
for exactly the same reason
that and I said overly high precision
on some sort of expectation
would lead to a constant pervasive
background error as you're not hitting
that high level of expectation.
And then just like Feldman
Barrett suggests in Simmons,
you have to flip because the system just
doesn't have unlimited resources.
And then the one that I'm most interested
in today actually is social media,
which is turning out
to be a fantastic way
of bending our generative model
into all sorts of shapes
that cause suboptimal outcomes. Right.
And that makes sense.
It's just giving us wave after wave of
misinformation through
filtered images and staged images
and of course, social media platforms.
Some social media platforms
function just like addictive substances
or like casinos in a way.
So again,
they're hijacking the precision system
in just the sorts of ways
that cause these problems.
OK, I just want to quickly summarize
before I go onto
why what I think the natural mechanisms
that keep us out of these problems are so
well-being as optimal model generation
importantly depends on correct
and flexible
are not these stuck insulated outcomes
but correct inflexible
self estimations of uncertainty.
So that's precision assignments.
So mis assigning
precision to prediction errors,
which can happen in lots of ways,
especially in our in our modern world,
will inevitably lead to suboptimal styles
of self-organization, suboptimal
generative models, and with that,
the production of pathological beliefs
and pathological behaviors.
And so that's how it can go wrong,
or at least that's the starting point.